cool now we get on to the triangle so
here's a triangle that I've got here now
I'll open this here but with any counter
a problem okay because how do we go from
the square to the rectangle we said well
you divide it up into a whole bunch of
squares and then you have this way this
way this may be straight and then you
multiply but you can't divide up
triangles into you can't it squares into
do you always have gaps and you can't
fit rectangles into it you always have
gaps so what do you do okay now you're
giving me the answer but you're not
telling me why it is there yeah okay all
right let's let's get on this idea again
I think there's some issues with it but
working we can tease them out we're on
the right track this train
I can't divide it up into rectangles or
squares but I can divide a square or
rectangle to get a triangle so I only go
in reverse so do that I've got some
dimensions on here they'll help me so
there we go so what am I got here um
just as before I've got them up down
right but instead of calling it length
we call it height and then across the
bottom
it's B as well but it's B for base base
okay drop the best now where is the
rectangle of a square that this comes
from okay now you got to be careful
let's come back to the Sun rectangle did
here okay just suppose this was it and I
divided it across
okay so first since I'm a genius I think
good so now I've got a triangle right
but I've got a very special triangle see
this triangle here is one at the top
what's its angle in the corner right
it's a writing rigor 90 degrees
now not every triangle out there is a
nine as a 90
for example this one does not right so
therefore you can't go ahead and just
use these rooms all the time because
this triangle doesn't obey that
particular rule so I have to do
something else yeah sad again you can
wait so here's what I'm going to do you
see how I have divided this particular
triangle up in half with this height
okay so in this triangle in our two
frames that make sense and I'm actually
gonna number them right so call this one
number one now if you have a look at the
first trial over there on the left you
can see that if I copied that triangle
like so and then just turn it around a
little bit I can shove him up against
there like so okay so this is a copy of
triangle one it's the same area that's
really important right and if I put them
together triangle on triangle one now
what if I got that's a rectangle and you
see I've got a right angle here just
like I was talking about before so it
doesn't take that much imagination to
see that I can play the same game
we're triangle to right so you should
make sure that the orientation so this
is a copy of triangle two again spun
around and matched up so that what I get
is another rectangle over here okay so
now compare the rectangle with this
yellow triangle down here right cuz
that's what we really want the area of
this triangle well when you think about
the whole rectangle that I've made by
adding up all of these triangles to get
up what's the area of that whole
rectangle stop the whole rectangle yeah
um hello which in this case is 5 times
me which is this base yes
B times H which is that whole rectangle
right the whole rectangle but I don't
like the whole rectangle if I get rid of
these on extra props now right this is
exactly equal to what I've left I've
taken half of it away right if I don't
you know here you go you can even see it
if I put it here and there yeah it's
very okay so therefore it's divided by
two and that's where you get your
familiar 1/2 base times height now you
let this two years ago
okay this is a year a but the reason
wavering this is precisely because of
the answers that could called out you
can't just quit this you have to know
why they are right
this is a basic shapes we can understand
this but you won't understand the
reasons behind it right one more shape I
mean there are more but we're just gonna
do one more today this guy does this guy
starts with a P its parallelogram I can
tell you it's not a rhombus cuz clearly
that looks longer than that right
parallelogram
it's not a rhombus because the sides are
all equal I can tell you tonight a kite
because see and we'll actually how it
will mark this one so here's your
parallelogram you can cut one out okay
one second because I'm answer in the
middle of answering another question so
you'll have to wait have a look at the
sides because there are some equal sides
there are some pairs but which ones are
they for instance see this one up here
what's it equal to its that's exactly
right
the opposite sign okay when you have a
look at the other parasites they're also
opposite right now when opposite sides
are equal
that's a parallelogram if one wanted a
client
he's a kite it still got two pairs of
equal sides but where are they they're
not opposite of it they're adjacent very
good so that gives you a client this
gives you a parallelogram well kind of
see a problem the problem is the pole is
diamond the word diamond it's used
ambiguously like for example in baseball
there's a diamond you know what shape
the diamonds in it's kind of its kind of
square really like what diamonds are
don't use the word diamonds okay cuz it
could mean you know doesn't quite say
the same when it's like shining bright
like a rhombus like it just doesn't work
all right can we move on son right all
right so here's my parallelogram now
what I would suggest you do is despite
how beautiful this is
and it actually this actually is also a
parallelogram but I actually think this
looks very much like it looks like a it
looks like a rhombus all right which
means that like you might think that you
can use the rules of a rhombus which are
different we'll get to them I'm writing
right width in which you can't okay so
that's why I've deliberately made this
longer than this edge show that you can
see that it's not of rhombus words with
this one it's kind of dicey keep using
it it's fine
yeah that's my point though they close
okay now what are we gonna do here would
someone like to give me a suggestion
okay cut off the end cut off weekend so
so where is this end so for example
right it's kind of like this isn't it by
the way this has a special name you
should note it down right see that line
which gives us a perpendicular height in
this case right that one perpendicular
is important when it's perpendicular and
you get that pipe this line is called
the altitude just like just like you
know altitude in the air so what you're
gonna do is create a similar kind of
thing here the perpendicular height okay
now if I get my pre-fabricated one here
here is where I see let me try get my
finger out of the way
he's where I see us cutting off one end
right and that vertical line there
that's going to be the altitude now what
I want to do is move this guy around to
here okay now when I do that here's what
I should produce okay here he is what's
left over after I've cut off that
triangle onion can you see that it's
been locked off and I put it in dotted
line so you can see what's happening
that's where the triangle used to be and
now I'm going to rearrange it over to
this side here so now you can clearly
see right remember how how did I choose
this vertical line why did I cut it
along this way
why didn't I cut it like some other way
what was special about that line
say that again okay true remember right
just like in the triangle yeah I need to
do some rotation stuff would not or if I
cut this way I wouldn't get a rectangle
I just get another parallelogram which
is the same problem that I started with
right so if you cut this line
perpendicular just like this altitude
then when you bring it over here
it'll be perpendicular over here as well
which is just like a rectangle okay so
now I've got my base I've got my quite
right which are the same as this base
here and this fight so therefore the
area of parallelogram and make sure you
spell it right it's got an O in the
middle okay it's equal to very simply
the base times the perpendicular height
give me H make sense yeah because pH
would be two letters and in algebra
every letter is its own number so we've
only got two things here in fact by the
way if I make this a little clearer see
s squared is just s times s right
do you remember how I made a point
earlier when we said area is the space
taken up by a two dimensional two
dimensional shape you can see the two
dimensions every time look one two one
two one two one two
every time you're working out an area
you'll get two dimensions